the failed former president Donald J
Trump is now suggesting that Republicans
work to wreck the economy for the next
two years because that would be good for
Trump in 2024. if you could imagine a
more depraved
anti-American idea to benefit oneself
politically than this I quite frankly
can't think of it I mean if if you put a
gun to my head which many of these
people would gladly do I guess the worst
scenario would be allow or even
encourage a terrorist attack in order to
place me as the person in charge to
unite the country after the attack to
increase my approval rating that if you
say to me can you think of something
worse than let's wreck the economy uh it
would probably be that let's take a look
at what Donald Trump posted to his
platform truth social yesterday truth
essential very very like there's a
serious lack of Truth here posted in all
capital letters as Donald Trump often
does
saying quote Republicans can get almost
everything back that the old broken Crow
Mitch McConnell and the real leader
china-centric Coco Chao he by the way
he's he's referring to Mitch McConnell's
wife Elaine Chao that is his sort of
racist xenophobic nickname for her
stupidly gave up to the Democrats over
the last two years by simply playing
tough in the upcoming debt ceiling
negotiations Trump is saying don't
negotiate allow the government to
completely shut down allow basic systems
to fail which will wreck the economy and
then that'll help Republicans in 2024.
that's what Trump is saying you have to
read between the lines here and it's
pretty easy to figure out what he's
saying with the right negotiators like
all of those involved the other night on
both sides for speaker
it will be a beautiful and joyous thing
for the people of our country to watch
make America great again Trump thinks
the American people would enjoy watching
basic Services go unfunded due to
political maneuvering because it would
be
good TV I mean
the depravity here is one level but
actually I want to put that aside for a
moment put aside for a moment the
immorality the depravity the lack of
ethics of this idea of ruin the economy
so that then Trump can swoop in in 24
and say look you need to be back and
I'll fix all of this right away put it
aside for a second
I actually believe it's bad political
strategy the long-term consequences of a
damaged economy I believe outweigh the
short-term political gain it takes a
long time and a huge amount of resources
to recover from an act of deliberately
screwing up the economy for two years
and forget about would it be irreparable
let's concede it's reparable but you
could be talking about years quite
frankly
if you were to say let's unite and let's
not do the debt ceiling if and when it
comes to be necessary if we need
stimulus because of some crisis let's
not do it if we need funding for a
natural disaster let's not do it on and
on and on and on right
I actually believe that the damage you
do will reach far beyond the two-year
term that you think would basically be
compartmentalized nicely to help you in
2024 because deliberately wrecking the
American economy in order to win future
elections of course it's unethical of
course it lacks Integrity of course it's
a total abandonment of the principles
their principles give me a break it's an
abandonment of the principles they claim
to to to uh value and of course it harms
Society in the short run but it's bad in
the long run and as a result it's also
not a good idea for the political for
the Republican party now Trump views a
wrecked economy as a key to his election
in 2024. he expects that Kevin McCarthy
is going to honor some kind of
commitment to wreck the economy to Trump
that would be insane if it is the case
and they need to be held accountable if
they do that now let's be honest if if
we if nothing else I'm honest with all
of you
if we are honest even when Republicans
don't say it or don't realize it
their actions have been disastrous for
the economy for decades now
that's just the reality trickle-down
economics where you cut taxes for the
rich to
raise the tide for all boats it doesn't
work
flat out doesn't work we've had
economists on we've looked at the data
just doesn't work and so Republicans
would never say we're going to cut taxes
on the rich to wreck the economy no they
they might even think it helps the
economy but it doesn't so the policy has
been bad for the economy for a very long
time
um Reagan exploded uh spending while
cutting taxes it's been policy for a
very long time Bush started two Wars
created the Department of Homeland
Security and TSA while giving tax cuts
to the rich
come on it's the same thing Trump added
trillions in debt while giving tax cuts
to the rich this has been what they've
done for decades but now Trump is just
openly saying let's screw it up let's
screw it up and then Americans will
figure out how much they want
Republicans in 2024. it's absolutely
disgusting almost as disgusting as the
very ugly war between Lauren bobert and
Marjorie Taylor green let's talk about
that next
it's a new year many of us are trying to
make new positive changes here's
something really simple that could be a
game changer our sponsor athletic greens
every day I take a scoop of ag-1 I get
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients to last
me all day long this way I just know my
nutritional bases are covered for the
entire day it has everything I want and
that's important to me rather than doing
the individual supplements and vitamins
or whatever I don't want to do any of
that okay ag1 is the simplest way to
just get everything I want for my
nutritional Foundation each day ag1 is
also a great bang for your buck you're
going to end up spending way more on all
those bottles of vitamins and
supplements and minerals so save some
money make your life easier just a scoop
of ag1 I love the travel packs which let
me take ag1 wherever I go I have the big
pack of ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below